It’s October 4, 2018.
The heat from the arena lights shine bright on the Tigers new head coach.
It’s a coronation for the prodigal son of Memphis.
But for Penny Hardaway, this moment
began years ago…with a wish from a dying friend.
They became a closer-knit basketball team
with Penny coaching, but they knew all the time they was doing it for Dez
and it gave them the drive, the will. They wanted to win for Desmond.
In the Binghampton area, it was tough because you had gangs,
negative things going on in the neighborhood, and you had
to be really strong not to be a part of those negative things.
I think kids growing up in Memphis, it was—it's different generations.
I grew up in the era where around my family there was hustlers,
being exposed to the life of street life, you know what I'm saying,
like, negative activity, hood life, you know, that a lot of people
unfortunately can't get around because they born in these situations.
Penny Hardaway was raised in Binghampton,
a neighborhood east of downtown Memphis.
A few doors down lived Desmond Merriweather.
As the two grew older they forged what would become a lifelong basketball bond
right here on these courts by Lester Middle School.
We were probably—maybe 10, 11, 12 years old, somewhere in there
and we were in the park and I just knew Desmond, he was really competitive.
Huge personality. Happy-go-lucky guy. Loved to laugh.
But when it came to competing
he would fight you to, I mean—he would fight you, honestly.
If I get beat, I got to come back, I got to get revenge
because Dez now, he's small, but he's got a mouth.
Dez was very competitive even though he was small in stature,
and he would push Penny because he was saying
“You're bigger than me, you're stronger than me, can you take me?”
-It made me tougher. I didn't wanna lose either. It didn't matter if he was smaller
or not, I was gonna play him tough and didn't take it easy on him.
And he didn't want anybody to take it easy on him, so it helped both of us.
Penny would go on to star at the high school, collegiate and pro levels.
Dez played 4 years at Lane College in Jackson, Tennessee.
After graduating he returned to their childhood neighborhood
to coach the Lester Middle School team,
the same middle school that both Dez and Penny attended.
Dez loved the children, and I think he wanted to rush college
as fast he could just so he could get back here to coach children.
Hard-nosed coach. You got to play hard to play for him can't be soft.
Had to be able to run through a wall for him if he asked you to
cuz he gives his all, so he expects that in return.
He wasn't just teaching basketball. He was teaching morals and standards.
The children really felt united and together and
they had a purpose, and once they got to winning,
the children, everything, they—their behavior changed.
But just as the team started to thrive, Dez’s health began to decline.
One day he stopped by and I said, "Dez has lost a lot of weight."
He said, "I have colon cancer."
I just passed out and he was like, "Mom, wake up. Please get up."
He looked at me and he said, "Mom, you know, I can't believe this.
I am a person that do for everybody, anybody," and he said, "Me? Why me?"
You know, so we sit there and we hugged one another and we both cried.
With the cancer came along with the pain
but Desmond still worked through that in games.
I could tell through his facial expression and stuff but
a lot of people in the audience and stuff didn't know what he was going through
but he was struggling to make it.
-He went through multiple surgeries. The second surgery
he wanted some paper and he scribbled on the paper one cent.
I was like, "One cent?"
So Marty said, "Are you referring about Penny?"
He couldn't speak because he was on the ventilator, he thumbsed up.
He said call One Cent cuz he wanted him to, as sick as he was
he wanted Penny to coach the team for him, and that's what he was thinking about.
He needed somebody that he knew he can trust
and knew that not only would—
he knew that Penny would teach them more than just basketball.
His wife called me and said that Desmond was in the hospital
and they had given him 48 hours to live. I'm like, "What?"
I mean, he didn't have any signs or, if he did, he didn't tell anyone about it
and it went from no signs to going to the hospital and a routine checkup
to see what was going on to, you know, like, stage 4 cancer.
He smiled when he saw me come in and I kept
saying to him, "Look man, let's get you well and we'll get to the basketball."
He was like, "Naw man, I'm telling you, my middle school team,
we're really good. He said, "Man, I know that you're the only guy
that can save our neighborhood, and that's why I told them to call you.”
Dez recovered and Penny kept his pledge,
staying to help Dez coach Lester Middle School.
Even though the team was excelling, the kids were still being exposed
to the same dangers that Penny and Dez faced during their childhoods.
The same thing goes on today. It's just it's faster because of the internet.
It's because of the way the world's shifting with social media.
So kids could also get exposed to a lot of things way early
and soon and not having to be directly in the household with it.
Back then if you wasn’t directly with it
you wasn’t exposed till you heard about it.
Now you can be directly exposed to it indirectly.
Gang-banging, drug-dealing. Fighting all the time, killing.
It's a lot of fighting. Police running around, gunshots. You see it all.
Carpenter Street, you know what I'm saying, I can't,
I can't cuz you know the police might go back and look at this.
I can't say it.
Dez knew the territorial gang politics would always be a day-to-day struggle
a challenge he met head on.
When I first got there, there were a couple kids that were in gangs
and it was distracting them.
Dez thought that they were gonna get injured or killed
so he went to the gang leaders and said, "Hey, you know,
you see these kids from the basketball team, call me.
They're not supposed to be here.
We don't want them here.
We want to get them a different path and we're going in a different direction.
We don't want them to be a part of this gang."
Everybody loved him.
He had so much respect and love from around the neighborhood
that they, they granted him that wish.
With the players protected Penny and Dez coached Lester Middle School
to 3 state championships.
The basketball team helped him because he was living through the kids.
He didn't know how much time he had, but he knew
his love for those children and wanting to see them succeed
would help prolong his life, and it did.
Sunday, February 8th, 2015.
Penny got a text message that he knew one day was coming.
They texted me and said, "Hey, get to the house, you know, he's dying."
And uh, went to the house right after church
and as I was going through the door he was trying to speak.
Desmond kind of like lifted his head up
to tell Nikc that he love him and—
then Penny came, and as sick as he was
he still was trying to, you know, hold his head up to look up
to look at the end of the bed and tell him he loved him.
-I could understand that he told me that he loved me back
and then all of a sudden it just went blank. He just went—
two deep breaths and then it was over.
Like it—I just witnessed that like, saying that I love you.
He said he loved me
and then he just took two deep, deep breaths and then it just—
that was it.
Man, I couldn't believe it. I never witnessed anything like that
especially from a loved one, someone that I cared about.
To be able to witness that and to see what he had gone through up until that point,
it was almost like half of me was really sad
and the other half was "He's not in pain anymore."
Desmond Merriweather died at the age of 41.
The city of Memphis still mourns his loss.
The grassroots basketball movement Dez generated
will be felt for generations
spawning some of the top high school and collegiate players in the nation.
In our neighborhood he was the man, you know.
Everybody knew that he loved our neighborhood and he wanted it to do well.
He said our neighborhood needed a lift and
he gave his heart and he gave his soul
and his body and his life to those kids.